يبقى اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
استشهاد فتى فلسطيني بعد اصابته برصاصه في
الراس اطلقها جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
خلال اقتحام مخيم بلاطه شرقي نابلس ما
اسفر ايضا عن اصابه ثلاثه فلسطين
لدى سلطات الاحتلال التي حصلت احد المنازل
وبدورها اكدت مجموعه عرين الاسود
لجنود الاحتلال بينما اكدت مصادر فلسطينيه
اندلاع اشتباكات المسلحه عنيفه بين
مقاومين فلسطينيين وجنود الاحتلال قبل
انسحابهم من المخيم
من جهتها نعت حركه حماس الشهيد الفتى عامر
ابو زيتون الذي قتله جيش الاحتلال خلال
اقتحام مخيم بلاطه فجرا اليوم
وقالت حماس في بيان ان دماء الشهداء ستكون
نورا يضيء طريق المقاومه والتحرير ويشد
عزم الشعب الفلسطيني للنفيري وضرب المحتل
ومستوطنين في كل ارجاء الوطن
والثواب نابلس الذين تصدوا لاقتحام قوات
الاحتلال داعيه ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني
لمواجهته مخططات الاحتلال وجرائم حكومته
المتطرفه
وفي الاسماء اعتقلت قوه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي 11 مواطنا فلسطينيا في انحاء
مختلفه من الضفه الغربيه الليله الماضيه
وفجر اليوم
بان من بين المعتقلين عضو المجلس الثوري
لحركه فتح صالح الياسيني من مخيم الفارعه
في محافظه طوباس شمالي الضفه
باسل البرغوثي الذي تدعي قوته الاحتلال
انه مطلوب لها بالضغط عليه نفسه
من البلدات واقتحمت المنازل وعبثت
بمقتنياتها واقتادت المعتقلين الى معسكرات
للتحقيق معهم بتهمه مقاومه الاحتلال
واعمل رام الله معنا الان مدير مكتب
الجزيره وليد العمري اذا التصعيد مستمر من
الجانب الاسرائيلي ضعنا في صوره اخر
تفاصيله وردود الفعل الفلسطيني عليه
الرسمي لكل هذه الجرائم وهذا التصعيد من
جانب قوات الاحتلال الشهيد عامر ابو زيتون
فتى في ال 16 من عمره وقتله جنود الاحتلال
بعيار الناري اصابه في راسه خلال اجتياحهم
وتمولهم في مخيم بلاطه لاعتقال احد
المطلوبين واصابه ثلاثه لكنه هو الشهيد
الرابع منذ بدايه هذا العام بمعنى ان هناك
شهيدا كل يوم في الاراضي الفلسطينيه وواضح
ان حكومه اقصى اليمين المتطرف التي تحكم
في اسرائيل هي تنافس الحكومات التي سبقتها
ايضا ولذلك تواصل تصعيد الموقف في كافه
ارجاء الضفه الغربيه واضح ان هناك ليليا
عمليات قتل وعمليات اعتقال متواصله وما
جرى الليل الماضيه وفجر هذا اليوم خاصه في
منطقه شيكولاته وقريه بيت ريما ومناطق عده
اخرى مؤشر على ان هذه الحكومه ماضيه في
حملاتها لاعتقال الفلسطينيين وايضا فتح
النيران بشكل عشوائي الفتى ابو زيتون كما
ورد من شهود الايام اصيب في راسه وهو
مؤكداته وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه بمعنى ان
اما نيران قناص قد اصابته او انه اطلقت
النيران من قبل قوات الاحتلال بشكل عشوائي
فاصيب هذا الفتاه واستشهد في الوقت نفسه
همم في بيان اصدره مجموعات عرين الاسود
وهي مجموعات مقاومه في فلسطينيه في منطقه
نابلس فان عناصرهم قد اشتبكت مع قوات
الاحتلال وان نتبادل الاطلاق النار دار في
المكان وفي الاحتلال من ناحيتها تقول بان
حملاتها هذه سواء في بلاطه او في المناطق
الاخرى هي تاتي ضمن عمليتها العسكريه
المتواصله
منذ نيسان الماضي نيسان اييي ابريل الماضي
والتي تطلق عليها باسم حارس الاسوار وان
هدفها ملاحقه الفلسطينيين الذين تدهمهم
بالمقاومه في كافه ارجاء الضفه الغربيه
لكن كما ذكرت في البدايه ابو زيتون هو
الشهيد الرابع منذ بدايه العام الحالي اي
خلال اربعه ايام الماضيه هو رابع شهيد
يسقط في بنيران قوات الاحتلال الفلسطينيه
وهو ما يشير الى ان هناك شهيدا على الاقل
في كل يوم بالاضافه الى عمليات الاعتقال
المتواصله همم حتى الان هناك اكثر من 70
عمليه اعتقال منذ بدايه العام الجاري ووضح
ان الحكومه الحاليه بترتيبتها اليمنيه
المفرطه في تطرف فيها تستهدف الفلسطينيين
همم ليس فقط بسبب وجود حزب عنصريا مثل
الصهيونيه الدي وما يبحث عنه قادته هذا
التحالف وهم سموتش همم وايضا بين كبير من
تصعيد ضد الفلسطينيين وانما واضح بان هذا
قد يسكل مقدمه اذا ما تواصل الى انفجار قد
لا تحمد عقباه لاحد خلال ايام المقبله
شكرا جزيلا وليد العمري